movies are like games of Jenga if just
one piece is out of place the entire
thing collapses
no matter how well built the rest of it
is even movies that otherwise we're
great have been ruined by a bad decision
here's a look at movies that were
destroyed by just one scene The Dark
Knight Rises The Dark Knight Rises was
full of little head-scratching moments
such as if the villains plan is to blow
up Gotham after holding it hostage why
did you wait all those months to do it
most of these you can just let slide but
the reveal of Joseph gordon-levitt's
real identity that's that's just too
much I travel regal man you should use
your for news I like that name Robin you
know Robin of course in the comics
Robin's real name is dick or Jason or
Tim or Damian or even Stephanie but
apparently any of those names would have
been too subtle for movie audiences so
they hit you over the head with it
instead it's like revealing the students
name is John Aquaman or something
interstellar as a climax of christopher
nolan sci fi interpol and land inside a
far-flung future device that lets him
send cryptic messages to his daughter in
the past or in other words you have to
use some hippy dippy Morse code machine
to save the future using that's right
the power of love no no no no really
love that's the secret to unlocking the
mysteries of the space-time continuum
right why didn't they just end the movie
with this song then
powerful media there was a minute there
where it looked like Ridley Scott's
Prometheus was going to be one of the
coolest movies ever made but what it
turned out to be was a slow exercise and
cluelessness plenty of fans either loved
or hated but it's hard to argue about
that one sequence where the characters
have to avoid being crushed by a rolling
spaceship it looks tense exciting
thrilling even right up until you ask
yourself why didn't they just move to
the side instead of trying to outrun it
in fact the main character lives by
simply rolling three feet now if she had
only told her buddy to do the same thing
maybe we wouldn't have left a theater
feeling profoundly stupid her 12 years
of slave throughout the majority of 12
years of slave the story of solomon
northrup a free man who was kidnapped
and forced into slavery is artfully told
through brutal visuals and compelling
performances than Brad Pitt shows up and
he speaks using whatever accent this was
supposed to be but is Brad Pitt acting
in a Brad Pitt's face my freedom is
everything fact that I can walk out here
tomorrow brings me great pleasure
start walking Brad I would give us great
pleasure Let The Right One In Let The
Right One In is a rare kind of horror
movie a haunting character study with
few loud moments or over it scares it is
simply put an excellent creepy flick but
it does have one massive unintentional
belly-laugh moment that kind of ruins it
[Music]
here's a free tip to any future horror
movie directors if you want to keep your
audience terrified and on the edge of
their seats just skip the evil attack
kittens kittens can't really pull off
the evil thing you know they're just too
damn cute Star Wars special edition in
1997 fans were excited at the chance to
see the remastered Star Wars trilogy on
the big screen and then this happened
that you have in an instant people
realize George Lucas hadn't improved the
series with special editions it ruined
it the collective scream of distraught
fans is still reverberating around the
universe of the great disturbance in the
force as if millions of voices suddenly
cried out in terror and were suddenly
silenced well maybe not exactly silent
Return of the Jedi special edition now
you can almost understand the thought
process behind having grito shoot first
but for every revision Lucas has
explained there are at least three
others made to the trilogy that are just
random and bizarre and none of them are
more random or more bizarre than the
insanely stupid Jedi rocks dance number
in the middle of Return of the Jedi
prepare yourself there a bad feeling
[Music]
oh yeah I don't really have a lot of
chords to be very nice today
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all the school stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]